I still get so excited when I see that
valves big win with rumor on Dancing
with the Stars a career-making moment
and achievement and Here I am with
valves big bro max how proud are you of
little brother very proud yeah no
they're probably mean I know what it
takes it took me a lot longer than it
took him but for you to go all the way
and actually hoist the trophy is a big
deal you said you will not return to
Dancing with the Stars I'm not coming
back not because I'm not coming back cuz
I mean you know I have some problems
with the show no it's because I don't
have the contract I've moved on with my
life
I will I will entertain the idea of
being part of the show in some other
capacity I may have came across angry in
some instances in the past I've made
mistakes we've reconciled with some
people that you know we weren't really
cool with I'm also I'm also an
entrepreneur and I'm interested in other
things well let's talk about sway a
dance trilogy that's coming up tell us
about that you've Aalto knee meryl your
partner you won with season 18 yeah so
Merrill's friends part of this Peter's
part of this business storyline is
called the square dance trilogy you know
it's a little bit for everybody you also
love acting we we want to have a little
bit of fun with you can you can you
throw out a couple of iconic movie lines
for us we want to test you here we've
got Dirty Harry you've got to ask
yourself one question do you feel lucky
do you punk
congratulations on everything thank you
so much good to see you Maxon you can
catch sway on June 5th and 6th at the
Hammerstein Ballroom I'll be amazing
you